all right so the big media story over
the last 48 hours was Wednesday night's
CNN Town Hall of the failed former
president Donald Trump on yesterday's
show we did an extensive review of what
was said the audience's role and
reactions laughing and cheering at the
most depraved anti-democratic and
dishonest moments anchor Caitlin
Collins's respectable attempt to do some
fact checking up against the unfortunate
reality that Trump mostly steamrolled
right over her had the crowd on his side
for the lies and that the environment in
some total didn't really conform to one
where serious fact-checking and pinning
Trump down could happen in part because
of the crowd and because of the format
and so many other things so we then
heard again on yesterday's show from
people in the media
uh Joe Scarborough and others members of
the House and Senate we heard from all
sorts of different people about the town
hall and we heard from voters as well
and in a focus group that CNN did of
trump supporters they were not more
impressed or less impressed by Trump
based on the town hall it did nothing
one way or the other to influence their
opinion of trump and then the question
becomes well what about independent
voters what about Democrats what about
non-trump Republicans and it's hard to
imagine that they were overly thrilled
by what took place so now there's a
media question
what happens with CNN after this insane
Town Hall we know that based on the new
relatively new leadership of CNN by
Chris Licht that there is a change of
Direction happening that's already
happened the network has hired a number
of Republic former Republican officials
and so on to to be on the network but
Chris Licht did tell Kara Swisher during
an interview back in November that CNN
is not going to become the Trump News
Network this was the current head of CNN
Chris Licht speaking with Kara Swisher
you ended up talking about him for eight
hours a day and we're not going to do
that we're going to be very
um clear and take everything on a
case-by-case basis about what level of
coverage it should be so meaning that it
will not be quite hands we are not going
to be a 24 7 Trump News Network okay
um is that what they are sticking to or
is it not and to be clear
Trump is a former president
in the completely unprecedented
situation where he is under criminal
indictment was recently found liable
civilly for sexual assault and
defamation tried to hang on to power
despite having lost
on and on and on all these different
things so it makes sense that corporate
media talks about the guy it makes sense
but the question is what is the sort of
tone and tenor of that coverage is it
sycophantic is it uh uh what what
exactly is it going to be now just as
interestingly in the 48 hours since the
Trump Town Hall
during which Chris Licht defended what
CNN did there has been some I guess we
could call it light Rebellion coming
from within uh within CNN there's an
interesting article on uh semaphore
America was served very well by what we
did last night CNN chairman defends Town
Hall but
um there are others who are quoted here
the view from CNN staff is that it may
not be particularly the best thing and
they point out that they don't love the
fact that the audience was filled with
Trump supporters CNN senior media
reporter Oliver Darcy wrote It's hard to
see how America was served by the
spectacle of lies that aired on CNN
Wednesday evening
um and Licht said I absolutely
unequivocally believe America was served
well so there's a couple different
questions here question one is what
actually happens on CNN as far as Trump
coverage goes does it become friendlier
than maybe what we saw in 2016 in 2020 I
don't know that's certainly one question
the other aspect to this is what about
disaffected Fox News viewers because
that's part of the timing of this entire
thing Trump has increasingly turned
against Fox News over the last year now
with the firing of Tucker Carlson there
is a significant contingent of Maga
people who they may be watching Fox News
Now reluctantly or they may have
abandoned Fox News and they want a new
home does Chris Licht want to appeal to
those people
and does he want to try to make the new
home for those folks CNN and can he do
that in any way that is even remotely
responsible as far as journalism is
concerned or can you really only appeal
to those people by becoming overtly
sycophantic and brown-nosing about
Donald Trump a lot of questions in this
segment not a ton of answers we simply
have to wait and see but it's not
looking particularly inspiring I think
that's where we can leave it for today
failed former vice president Mike Pence
who is as much who basically failed as
hard as Trump did has been asked about
the verdict in which a jury found Donald
Trump liable for sexual assault and
defamation against e Gene Carroll Mike
Pence's reaction is I dare say
kafka-esque
he says he never saw Trump sexually
assault anyone
think about that for a second what do
you think about that verdict listen I
never saw Trump sexually assault anybody
wow big declaration Mike thank you let's
listen in my four and a half years
serving alongside the president I I
never heard or witnessed
behavior of that nature
I never personally witnessed Charles
Manson encouraged those people to go and
kill anybody he must not have done it
right a truly
spineless response from Mike Pence we
also had Pence weighing in on whether
the American people will in any way be
influenced by the fact that Trump now is
not only has been arrested and indicted
and might be arrested and indicted again
in a couple of months but was found
liable for sexual assault
he says Pence does he doesn't think the
American people will care well I think
that's a question for the American
people but I I really can't comment on a
judgment in a civil case I have no
knowledge of those matters and um uh I'm
sure the president uh will defend
himself in that matter and
but it strikes me that we it's a
it's just one more instance where
at a time when American families are
struggling he's really he's really
struggling to figure out what to say
about this to remain palatable to the
Maga crowd in case he does run
when our economy is hurting
when the world seems to become a more
dangerous place
almost every day that it's uh it's just
one more story uh focusing on my former
running mate that uh that I I know is a
great Fascination to members of the
national media but I just I just don't
think it's where the American people are
focused all right the American people
don't care because of inflation I guess
or something along those lines
um to me that sounds like a guy who
wants to say whatever he can say to not
anger the very Maga people who maybe if
Trump gets arrested again and his
campaign falls apart for whatever reason
Pence can jump in and say I'm going to
run Mega people who supported Trump back
when I was VP come with me to the
promised land or whatever the case may
be may be one of the most cowardly
spineless and self-serving people in
American politics right now would be
indeed Mike Pence and the the height of
absurdity of I never saw him engage in
that sort of behavior really does do you
think he does does a Serial sexual
assaulter habit literally do the
assaulting in front of other men I mean
I don't know there was the allegation
about Jeffrey Epstein and Trump doing
exactly that but uh not the vast
majority of the allegations that exist
so Pence pathetic as always polling like
three or four percent in most polls six
seven in some and maybe thinking
opportunistically is this uh let's leave
it with the question that was asked
will that civil liability verdict
affect Trump's standing
in either the primary or the general I
actually agree that the answer is no but
for a different reason than Mike Pence
says I think in the primary it won't
affect Trump at least not negatively
because for as many people in the
Republican primary voter electorate that
would be turned off by Trump being
liable for sexual assault there are
those who will be re-engaged because
they believe Trump is being treated
unfairly and that it's all a political
Witch Hunt so in the primary it'll
probably be flat in the general
um
I think that the cake is more or less
baked and it's basically a turnout thing
and maybe there are some people who
would turn out because they're angry
that Trump uh engaged in this behavior
and they want to vote against him but
it's also not clear to me that it's
going to shift the numbers in a general
election either I know it's crazy I know
it's crazy but that's where my head is
right now let me know what you think
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com
joinpakman.com the David packman show
continues to be a viewer and listener
funded program we depend on your support
through the membership program you can
Avail yourself of membership benefits at
joinpakman.com which is just an
extraordinary place to sign up for
membership it's quite frankly the only
place they tell me these days you can
use the coupon code indicted or the
coupon code indicated whichever you want
let's hear from people in the audience
on the Friday show we go to the phones
except we really don't we actually use
Discord you can join the David Pacman
show Discord absolutely free at
davidpackman.com
Discord and it's really an extraordinary
thing as a reminder to everybody who's
waiting the format for your nickname if
you want to talk to me is name and
location or location and name those are
the rules so for example we're going to
go to Juni from Florida Juni from
Florida is our first caller today Juni
what's going on
uh hello David do you hear me yes I do
great great uh my question for you is um
with everything you know going on with
the uh current Republican party with uh
you know uh Banning books trying to
restrict voting
um what do you think uh is the future of
uh the Republican party in your opinion
well I don't think it's determined at
this point in time I I as I've said for
a while now
um it looked like the 2022 Maga Red Wave
wasn't going to materialize and it
didn't and the question now is what
happens in 2024 there really doesn't
seem to be anything that will stop Trump
from being the Republican nominee short
of trump himself and what I mean by that
is one arrest so far five million dollar
sexual assault and defamation a verdict
against him on Tuesday potentially
another arrest coming out of Georgia in
uh between July and September is roughly
what's estimated
could all of that take him off the
campaign Trail in such a way that he's
just not viable but the Republican party
for now does seem to still hold Trump as
its leader and I don't know what's going
to prevent him from being the nominee so
then the question comes
uh becomes
the 2024 general election obviously if
Trump is re-elected president in 2024
which I don't think is as far-fetched as
some do Trump's actually ahead of Biden
in some polling already if that happens
then I will be ready to say the
Republican party in a more permanent way
has jumped the shark for lack of a
better term however if trumpism is again
defeated in 2024 assuming Trump's the
nominee but loses
I believe at that point particularly
with Trump being an even older guy at
that point in time it will be
essentially open season on abandoning
Maga fully by the Republican party which
may be what saves them at the end of the
day
okay yeah that sounds uh I you know I I
agree with that and uh can you do you
mind if I just ask you uh one more quick
uh question sure
okay great uh do you think with the
Republican party going against you know
the lgbtq community uh stigmatizing them
in uh very very negative ways uh do you
think it's fair to maybe call the modern
day Republican party fascistic or
proto-fascist in a way yeah I think uh
you know with a lot of this stuff these
are mostly
linguistic conversations than than
operational or or policy but I think
there's no question that what you're
seeing among the Maga movement is a sort
of neo-fascist light authoritarianism of
sorts which would like to be much more
hardcore if we didn't have some of the
checks and balances we have in the
United States they'd likely succeed in
becoming much more of that but um I I do
think that uh wannabe fascist
is probably as good a term as any
yeah I agree with that
um well okay David that's really all the
questions I've had and I don't want to
hold up so you know I'll just let you
get to uh more callers well one question
for you is Junie short for something
it's not a name I'm super familiar with
oh no that's okay it's uh it's a
nickname I go by because my full name is
Leroy McGraw Jr and so uh Juni just
comes from Junior got it okay very good
that makes that actually makes a lot of
sense all right Judy thank you for the
call I appreciate it no problem David
enjoy the rest of your weekend sir
YouTube there it goes Juni from Florida
let's go next to Daisy from is it from
reading or from reading reading and it's
spelled reading but I know that it's
pronounced different ways depending on
where in the world we are talking about
yeah um it's
it's reading reading actually how are
you doing David can you hear me I'm
doing well we have significantly
degraded audio quality where it's the
sort of like robot voice thing that's
happening but let's see if you can get
your question in if nothing else
oh boy okay David can you hear me better
I hope my question is
in the Republican party they seem to
focus around trends
uh people a lot
and I think it's because in my view that
uh that with trans people
they are making changes to their bodies
with
um like
you know with whatever their doctors
recommend right and they and the
Republican party is attacking this in a
way that they haven't attacked the
obviously teach community in the past
like with the the gay community for
example
and I'm just wondering your thoughts
about whether they will ever let up on
the trans Community like give us a break
kind of yeah I think so I mean as I've
said before
a while it was like when will they stop
obsessing about gay men and gay sex and
the answer unfortunately for the trans
Community was when they've moved on to
being obsessed with the Trans Community
I do believe eventually Republicans will
move on the problem is they'll scapegoat
some other group so someone else has it
coming to them if you know what I mean
yeah I understand that I just I'm hoping
for something to change
um I see a lot of change happening in I
think it's Montana
um with the
it was silent um silenced by the I think
they'll let the Republican legislature
there Daisy you cut out when you said
who was silenced but let me look into
what's happening in Montana I'm Gonna
Let You Go just because the connection
is really an uphill battle for us but I
do appreciate your question and uh
hearing from you about what is a very
important issue I do believe they will
move on from trans people but someone
else is going to then be uh in their
crosshairs which is a scary thing let's
go next to Jeremy from Chicago Jeremy
also a member at davidpackman.com Jeremy
I very much appreciate that
Jeremy you've muted yourself for some
reason I would love for you to unmute
yourself then you'll be able to talk to
me
oh hi can you hear me I can hear you yes
nice awesome cool
um so yeah um I I'm a member of your
show and yeah one of the reasons for
that besides the award-winning bonus
show which you make so much money off of
is the sound board and
the soundboard is so freaking hilarious
and I really appreciate it thank you I
appreciate that
my question about the sound board is
besides Obama and Truth Central right
what are your favorite sounds in the
sound board the uh the the technical
glitches when Trump does speeches and
the audio goes haywire and it frustrates
Trump or probably some of my favorite
ones also Trump trying and failing to
pronounce Indian names while he was in
India at a speech those have got to be
pretty near the top for me
that's for sure because I I think I
emailed you about adding more sounds to
the soundboard yes and we will do that
we're continuing to expand it
awesome awesome
um one more question
um Trump in 2024 assuming that he wins
the 2024 election do you think that he
will
um
find a way to
extend his presidential life no to
like not even 2028 no
like I'm just trying to like
ask this question in terms of like is it
I don't see him like
um
I think I know where you're going with
this you we don't it's hard to imagine
him leaving calmly and quietly if Trump
wins in 2024 he'll be inaugurated in
January 2025 and he will leave in
January 2029. I do not believe that he
is going to do anything to try to get
himself a third term
so about that like do you think he will
like this sounds this sounds so crazy
but like like trying to over rule or
repeal the 22nd amendment no because I
don't think so that's what I have yeah
no I don't think he's gonna do that I
think he'll do his uh his his years five
through eight and then he'll leave
you know peep is leaning into
dictators like poon and president XI
from China and so like I don't know
that's my assumptions that she wants to
stay present for as long as he wants yep
no I I think he's dangerous in a lot of
ways he tried to steal the election in
2020 but I think four more years at the
most is what we will have from Trump all
right Jeremy from Chicago great to hear
from you very much appreciate it let's
go next to Andrew from Massachusetts
Andrew from Massachusetts welcome to the
program what's going on
hi David can you hear me yes
so uh my question is related to the pbd
podcast and I'm actually halfway through
the Lex Friedman interview okay uh
thoughts about something that Lex said
about your appearance on the pbd podcast
um
so Lex suggested that while you and
Patrick probably have some disagreements
that many of Patrick's arguments with
you during that podcast were kind of
your conservative Playing devil's
advocate to bring out the best in you do
you recall him saying that I recall him
saying that yeah
okay so I think that's a pretty
charitable take yeah
yeah so I'm wondering what you think
about that
um especially given that I don't know if
you've heard that Patrick made a 100
million dollar offer to Tucker this was
obviously before he announced um he
would go into Twitter yeah but wondering
if you've heard about the 100 million
dollar offer and then I did so here's
the thing here's the thing Andrew
Patrick Bet David is a trump guy okay I
don't know how much I don't watch all of
his episodes by any means but it's very
clear he's a trump guy you know we
talked a little bit behind the scenes
like he's a trump guy that and that's
totally fine he's not like he doesn't
seem like an unhinged social
conservative although he sort of seems
to be delving into the trans stuff a
little bit but I think mostly for
economic reasons he kind of likes the
Trump stuff so when Lex Friedman said
that he thought a lot of what Patrick
was doing was just playing Devil's
Advocate I didn't agree but the thing
especially in a three and a half hour
interview like when I was on the Lex
Friedman show is I can't argue about
everything I disagree with and the call
I made as the interview was going on was
it doesn't make sense to kind of stop
the flow to argue about whether pbd was
Playing devil's advocate because Lex
wasn't actually there he watched it and
it's based on my recollect it wouldn't
have been an interesting place to kind
of like get into it if that makes sense
so that's why sometimes you just kind of
have to let things go in order to get to
something that you think might be more
interesting or substantive
all right thanks for the clarification
uh that's that's all I really had today
all right thanks there's Andrew from
Massachusetts uh with a question about
my discussion with Lex Friedman about my
appearance with Patrick Bet David both
of either of which I would be glad to do
again
let's go to Samantha from Philly
Samantha from Philly welcome to the
David packman show what's on your mind
today
hey David thanks for taking my call my
pleasure
um I really enjoy the show and I enjoy
when each
okay and
and taken to consideration
um specifically voting voting on issues
I guess and voting just politically
biasedness what do you mean
so I guess what I'm getting to is how
does how does polling take into
consideration new population trends that
haven't emerged yet as voters per se but
they will so you might so like an
example would be
if right now in May of 2023 you're doing
a poll of Texas voters about how they
plan to vote and you are normalizing the
sample based on the 2022 data for
example about gender and race and age
and all these different things but it
turns out for example that like by
2024's election there will be more
Latino voters and so you actually need
to account for that in your methodology
is that sort of what you're asking
that's exactly right it could be any
sort of demographic that explodes in the
next election but hasn't yet the answer
is basically there's two versions of the
answer and both are kind of right one is
different polls account for that in
different ways and if you read the
methodology page they will usually tell
you how they are how they are picking
their sample and adjusting their sample
and then you can look and say oh this
poll is adjusting the sample in a way
that does make sense and this one is
doing it in a way that doesn't the other
perspective will be
there's rarely polling done so far in
advance that the demographic changes
will be so big that they'll make more
than like a point of difference and so
like I actually think in many cases I
don't know offhand whether my my example
was the Latino population in Texas will
grow and Latino voters tend to vote
other than Cubans they tend to vote more
for Democrats than Republicans my guess
is even without accounting for what the
Latino population will be in November of
24 that the difference between now and
then isn't going isn't so significant
that you that you are going to be way
off if you don't account for the change
and use today's numbers that would be my
statistical guess
do you feel that the polling was
accurate before the that you've seen for
the midterms
uh I think it was well you know it's a
good question I think the problem with
that polling you know I'd have to review
it I don't remember I the the polling
generally said the most likely scenario
was Democrats keep the Senate and lose
the house and that did happen so in that
sense it was accurate yeah
yeah
it was accurate in that sense but you
know I don't know if the reporting is
just sensationalized but you know
everyone said it's historical the
numbers are historical we didn't see
this coming you mean the red wave that
they predicted would have been historic
or that what actually happened is
historic
what happened was historic oh it's
unusual certainly I mean democrats
should have done way worse than they did
but particularly in the two months
before the midterms the polling did
pretty closely reflect what ultimately
happened
okay well all right great that was my
question all right Samantha from Philly
thank you very much let's take just the
quickest of breaks we're going to keep
talking to people who are waiting uh so
so hang on if you're waiting to talk to
me we'll take a very quick break and
then be right back
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's hear
from a few more people we do calls on
the Friday show via Discord which you
can find at davidpackman.com
slash Discord I want to go next to
George from Virginia George from
Virginia welcome to the program what's
on your mind today
George you're on the air
George you probably have the wrong audio
device selected if you can fix that we
will then be able to hear you
all right George well uh unfortunately
the technical issues plaguing George
let's go to Dustin from Hamilton now
Hamilton could be I don't know how many
states have a Hamilton I think there's
even a Hamilton there's there's probably
a Hamilton in Canada as well so Dustin
from Hamilton I don't know where you're
really calling from uh maybe you can
tell us what's on your mind today
okay Dustin from Hamilton are you there
Dustin you've now muted yourself please
unmute yourself
all right two in a row folks this is not
common let's go to Freddy from the Bay
Area California I will soon be in the
Bay Area in California it's going to be
a beautiful thing Freddie what's going
on
all right hey man thanks for taking my
call
um
I was I don't know I don't know about
this all already I kind of joined in a
little late okay but I was just
wondering your thoughts on the
um George Santos indictments oh yeah on
the Wednesday show we talked about it
pretty extensively I have to tell you I
am not the type of person to take
pleasure in the failings of others but I
am delighted by the arrest of George
Santos because not because I go around
saying I don't like your politics and
you lied so you should get arrested not
because of that but because there's so
much evidence against the guy exactly
his actions warrant criminal charges and
now he's going to have to deal with it
and maybe he'll end up getting kicked
out of Congress who knows
right that's right that's what I'm
thinking like what do you think is going
to happen I mean do you think hopefully
he actually you know gets in trouble
this and doesn't actually be able to
stay in congress absolutely and you know
the truth is with this guy
people are already talking about prison
time I don't even care about that I just
want him out of the House of
Representatives it seems like it would
be a moral wrong for him to have gotten
away with what he got away with and to
serve out his full two years I want him
to suffer the humiliation of being
kicked out of Congress early and by the
way I don't have in front of me what the
rules are about how you qualify for like
the retirement packages from Congress
which are fantastic my thought is if he
doesn't make it a full term he doesn't
get any of them which would also be a
really great thing
right yeah he doesn't deserve any of
that it's just the way that he flaunts
around it's almost like he likes the
attention and it's going out going to
parties and stuff it's just like come on
he he doesn't deserve any of that stuff
the guy's pathetic he adds nothing he
adds nothing he really is Freddie can I
ask you a Bay Area question and get your
advice
sure so when I'm gonna be out there I am
going to basically have commitments
partially in San Francisco and partially
in Santa Cruz so my idea was to stay
somewhere roughly in between and so I
only have to drive half the distance
when I go to one or the other people
have said to me maybe look at Palo Alto
or Mountain View or whatever that seems
to be a little closer to San Francisco
than Santa Cruz but my question to you
is where
would be a convenient place to stay with
a nice walkable downtown with some
hipster coffee shops and the whole thing
that would be relatively convenient to
both cities what do you recommend okay
so Palo Alto yes that area and there's a
town called Saratoga okay right when you
go up and over the Santa Cruz mountains
yes you're closer to Santa Cruz but you
want to be closer to Santa Cruz right
now everywhere closer to San Francisco
uh no Saratoga I used to have to stay
there I was bringing my dog to a vet up
there actually but okay talking about
little hipster places coffee good little
places to eat small quaint very nice
good little hotels that's a great place
little parks to go walking I have I have
an 18 month old little girl and she was
probably eight months old at the time
and we're bringing her in the stroller
to these little parks and stuff
fantastic Place Saratoga I'm down in
Monterey right now so I'm gonna look
into that Freddy that sounds good that
sounds very good I'm gonna check into
that I appreciate the advice
yeah no problem at all all right there's
Freddie from the Bay Area beautiful
phone call folks I have to say
absolutely fantastic let's go next to
Nelson from Bethlehem Nelson from
Bethlehem Bethlehem welcome
hey there David
um great show so far this week thank you
you've been killing like usual
appreciate that very much
uh I don't think anybody's touched on
this yet today so I wanted to get your
opinion on them I don't think I've seen
it on your show
um are you familiar with Daniel Ortega
down there in Nicaragua in the
sandinistas
only superficially I don't have deep
knowledge
yeah they're um one of those groups that
you hear about a lot in the news but
never nobody ever really talks about
them um so back in September um Daniel
Ortega for anybody that doesn't know he
is
um like the one real communist leader
down there trying to um bring socialism
uh to South America
um again against the witches of the
United States
um in September he outlawed
um public displays of Christianity and
um about a month ago on Easter he went
and rounded up a bunch of journalists
and clergy members and um arrested a
bunch of people attending Catholic mass
now I'm an anti-theist I think that all
religion is bad and all of it needs to
be outlawed I just think he's being a
little heavy-handed with it
um I was having a discussion with some
of the chat members and a lot of them
are in favor I was just wondering um do
you think that we should um
like when it comes to it in the United
States uh do you think that people like
it should be a little bit more
heavy-handed against the Catholic church
and Christian religion or so here's the
thing okay there's two different layers
to this from the little let's talk about
the situation Nicaragua first and then
we'll talk more generally
it seems as though it's it the the goal
really is to actually go after political
opponents of Ortega under the guise of
this anti-religion stuff correct me if
I'm wrong but it seems that to some
degree they're not just randomly going
for the most part it doesn't seem like
they're randomly going after Catholics
but the idea is
targeting opponents of of Ortega is that
your understanding as well
um I would say 90 that is it but they're
also going after
um the normal people that are like out
blocking traffic with Easter parades and
stuff they're going after everyone's out
when that stuff is fair so that's an
important clarification my view is there
should be total separation of church and
state I don't ever want to hear
scripture cited by an elected official
during a debate about what the law
should be the way it's cited in the
United States about abortion about trans
issues about LGBT issues of all I never
want to hear that stuff I don't want to
see Ten Commandments displays at a
courthouse I I want separation of church
and state but
I also want freedom of religion which
includes freedom to follow any religion
or not
and not to be persecuted so to the
extent that the Catholic church has been
involved in child abuse cover-ups they
should receive absolutely no special
help whatsoever but to the extent that
you know being heavy-handed with just
people who go to church and worship just
because I don't do that doesn't mean
that I want the government going after
them so I I cannot in good conscience
support anything like that
okay well it's good to hear your opinion
on that and I would like to say as
another thing of clarification um it is
mostly political and a lot of it has to
go down to like racial lines because um
well a lot of the indigenous Community
down there is not Catholic and you know
it kind of bounces heads up against it
but thank you for giving your opinion on
that David I was just curious and uh
once again my brother soft gentleman is
listening in the call-in show you can't
call in but love you out there softly
and love you so much David thank you for
doing what you do does that mean is that
like soft serve what does that mean
no it's a nickname going back to when we
were in high school it's just the thing
that he did in theater class soft
gentlemen it's a long story oh boy I
hope it's uh appropriate for a PG
audience geez Nelson thank you very much
for the call it is okay good thank you
very much for the call and uh all right
let's continue let's go next to Ricardo
from one of my favorite cities
um I guess in North America uh Montreal
Ricardo welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
hello David how are you I'm doing well
good to hear hey uh I know that um uh
before I ask any questions
um I know this is something that
probably many in your audience have
asked you have asked you time and time
and again uh but it's actually more of a
comment but
um I think it would be great to to see a
debate between you and Ben Shapiro
sometime yeah well I'll do it anytime
we've invited him on the program and he
doesn't respond so he may be too big for
us now but uh he's welcome anytime I'm
glad to do that but it's he he's the one
you've got to convince not me
mm-hmm yeah of course yeah yeah uh but
yeah I remember uh some years back I
think maybe about 2019 I think I I
watched the uh the the debate between
you and Ben Benji are not sure if
there's any been any other debates I
think it was in 2013 you and then had
the debate but uh yeah I think that was
that was a good debate and I think yeah
in a way you you kind of like unraveled
his arguments especially about uh gun
gun control and all that
um but uh to tell you the truth I I know
that um uh when during the pandemic I
think the early stages pandemic when the
the whole George Floyd uh riots were
happening that's when I really started
like listening to you and not sure there
was actually a period time when I was
listening to you both you and Ben
Shapiro just to sort of get like the
left perspective and the right
perspective on the different things but
I do notice that uh over time it seems
that um his views on things got more and
more like extreme his views kind of got
more to the right of them if you noticed
that you know I don't follow Shapiro
super closely
but it does strike me that that entire
group Shapiro former actor Michael
Knowles Candace Owens they all seem to
have become dramatically more extreme
and I don't know if it's that they found
out that it's more profitable or
interesting or if they genuinely have
become more I I don't really know what
the reason is for it you know one of the
things that I've noticed is that my
political views have really not
dramatically changed over the last
decade and there's nothing right or
wrong with views changing if you get new
information you revise your views I
think that that's a really great thing
but it does strike me as odd
particularly based on their age you know
Dave rubin's another one who it's just
weird when at a certain age you have
such differing such changing views
because it suggests that your views as
an adult were already not super well
informed if they can change so radically
so it is kind of a weird thing
it is yeah I I agree 100 percent
and I know that in the past you have
also talked about how uh Dave Rubin
probably like when he was in his 30s or
40s uh he suddenly went from being
liberal or on the left to on the right
and in some ways he's even kind of like
on the radical right uh Joe I think uh
like there was a time I was actually
listen uh just just out of curiosity the
sake I was listening to a interview he
was doing with I think it was Michael
Knowles and and there are some things
that Dave Rubin still had views on the
left of like on abortion he still I
think he still uh agreed that abortion
should be accessible to all women and he
just said that he wasn't he wasn't like
ready yet to abandon that abortion
should be accessible so I thought that
was interesting
yet you know the Dave Rubin thing is
really perplexing to me because he's 46
years old now and so he had this
complete political 180 at like age 38
let's call it that's like I mean think
think for a second Ricardo how crazy it
would be if right now right at my me
current at my current age at this point
in my career I became a right-wing
extremist like that would be would you
would you even believe that or would you
assume I'm doing it because I can do it
profitably like is it even viable that I
would completely 180 My Views right now
it seems so insane
yeah I I guess if you you were to do
that theoretically that would be that
would strike me as like oh what's going
on here was he did he even have
left-wing views in the first place right
or or was I or Were My Views so poorly
grounded in reality that I didn't even
know what I believe I mean it would be
very weird when I think about it that
way now that I'm roughly the age that he
was when he did his thing it's really
strange it's it's really weird to
imagine
I agree it reminds me a bit of like how
uh you know when Trump was 60 and he
says oh yeah yeah I saw a kid and and uh
and and you know what I I think I'm
gonna be against abortion
and honestly I think he was like 66 at
that point it's even it's even harder to
believe yep I I think it's all very
weird and I do think that they've moved
further to the right Ricardo
I agree yeah and uh even even Jordan
Peterson I I was sometimes it happens
that I'll listen to some of his like
podcasts and some of the I don't really
listen as much as I used to but I think
I feel like even he's become more
radical like oh yeah I think he had
somebody he said he had somebody on his
show and he was using the term globalist
I'm like oh shoot oh yes that's really
crazy no he's lost his mind it's it's
really crazy what's going on and
unfortunately it's been normalized to
where they're seen as kind of like not
that extreme but these are really
extreme people Ricardo I got a rap but I
really appreciate you being bringing
this up
yeah no problem by the way before I go
uh just one question is there any right
wing uh people you'd like to have a
debate with next
not really I mean I'll talk to I'll talk
to whoever but I'm not like pining to
debate them you know they're pretty bad
faith actors in general
yeah I agree well thanks for having me
on I really appreciate it all right
Ricardo from Montreal Quebec Canada
great to see you great to hear you
rather uh that's gonna do it for today
I'm sorry I couldn't speak to everyone
but we will take calls again have a
great weekend unless you've got access
to the bonus show in which case we'll
see you in a moment
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right it's time for Friday feedback
the mailbag the Friday Feed Bag someone
actually wrote to me saying it should
really be called Friday Apple bags which
relates to a whole other thing from the
vaccine era anyway we don't even need to
get into that that's probably outside
the scope of today's conversation if you
have something to say and many of you do
you can email info at davidpackman.com
please keep them polite not everyone we
look at today will be polite be aware
that as you are furiously typing
comments on YouTube they might be
selected and end up in the Friday
feedback you never know and Reddit posts
and so on and so forth it all might end
up there all right let's start with
today's first one from YouTube user John
Cherokee who says yeah Tucker Carlson
was an American hero and I hope he will
get his own show where they can't fire
him because his message is very
important in addition to that Taylor
green is an American hero she's
basically standing virtually alone
basically virtually alone in Congress
defending the rights of the American
people this is a big fan not only of
Tucker Carlson but of Marjorie Taylor
green not a single a punctuation element
in this entire message unless you count
the apostrophe on she's but certainly no
uh sentences
um listen this is one of those things
where we all have to pick our battles
and the battles I pick on a podcast and
YouTube channel
and the battles you pick at the
Thanksgiving table
and that your sibling picks at the
Memorial Day barbecue which is upcoming
right whatever battles we all pick might
be different and for me I am not now
going to choose the Battle of trying to
convince someone who believes that
Marjorie Taylor green and Tucker Carlson
are the height of American patriotism
that they are wrong that is not a battle
that I am going to pick right now so
we're going to move on but these folks
exist and that's always important to
remember
DD 2023 DD says LOL I can't believe you
all are applauding high taxes for
everyone in some obscure version of
fairness that doesn't help you at all in
fact it damages you when the company you
work for moves to a different country to
operate or Cuts costs by changing your
health care benefits to a cheaper one or
flat out lays you off because you aren't
very efficient so dumb you know
I uh understand
and I'm in agreement with the reality
that if any tax gets too high it starts
to have an impact that is usually not uh
ideal and with most policy this isn't
unique to taxes in general with policy
in general with life
when you think about the extreme Tales
of normal distribution you start to see
distortions take for example like
exercise if you are completely sedentary
and sit all day at a desk and then at
home and then in your car and then
watching TV do no physical exercise
you're on one tail end of physical
exercise and that's bad for you on the
other hand if you become completely
obsessed with exercise to the point that
you can't hold the job and you're you're
destroying Your Body by working out 18
hours a day and sleeping for six or
whatever right at the extremes of these
bell curves there are problems and so
zero percent taxes would be a problem
because we can't have functioning
infrastructure
um and then 100 taxes as well and so
we're we're all kind of operating in the
gray area
but what is missed by lots of these
people who write stuff like this are
they don't get that most corporations
are passed through entities like s
corporations llc's and others and that
the so-called business tax rate from
which there are endless loopholes
applies to C corporations
but again I'm sort of like trying to
explain this to somebody who's not
willing to listen anyway but I am in
agreement that taxes shouldn't be too
high and how we Define that probably
differs uh between us Rocky Road said
look for real
as a 100
DieHard Trump supporter
I'd like one of David Pacman's audience
to explain this to me
how has Biden's first term been anything
other than a complete disaster I'm not
trying to troll I'm not looking to
insult I'm just 100 puzzled by this well
I like to apply something called the
burden of proof in these situations
I would love to hear from Rocky Road
what elements of Joe Biden's presidency
make it a disaster inflation reduction
act reasonably sized does some good
things changes to student lending small
changes to Health Care access
um uh stock market is doing fine
unemployment lowest since 1969 inflation
coming down
um no new Wars as they always like to
say you may say well but Russia invaded
Ukraine okay yeah but Biden didn't start
that war okay uh you know you make the
case make the case for the Biden
disaster because I look around and I see
wages up 4.4 over the last year
inflation down stocks okay new jobs
things seem like sort of all right
nothing's perfect we haven't solved a
whole bunch of systemic and structural
issues but sort of like seems like
things are going okay
uh this was a meme posted to our
subreddit I don't know how many of you
have been following the Stephen Crowder
situation where Stephen Crowder
um he's a right-wing talker
and he's getting a divorce and
surveillance of security camera footage
was released in which he's berating his
wife and it okay
here is conservative struggling
with conflicting Notions the Stephen
Crowder video is an invasion of his
privacy and shouldn't be blocked and
should be blocked rather versus arguing
that Hunter Biden's penis pictures
should be publicly available yeah
they've really gotten themselves into
now of course you know what they will
say right sometimes on the left we think
we really got them now we really got him
they will simply say that Hunter the
hunter Biden laptop story which included
the penis pictures
is more politically relevant
to American politics than what Stephen
Crowder has to say because Hunter is Joe
Biden's son or whatever we've already
debunked it in the sense that Hunter
Biden has nothing to do with the Biden
Administration and Stephen Crowder also
has nothing to do with the Biden
Administration so you know a little
something for everyone there
Descartes walks into a pub
says who could have predicted
stripping away rights and banning books
with Drive Away voters yeah this is
tongue-in-cheek but it really didn't
seem that Florida Republicans and other
Republicans understood
that the anti-woke Crusade that they are
waging isn't super popular with much
much of America
that much of a majority of America is
coming down on the side of Disney on the
side of drag shows existing and you can
choose whether you bring your kid or not
um dealing with structural problems that
affect trans people most of the country
is on the so-called woke side and so as
I've said before
a lot of these are good ways to raise
some money
in primaries in local races but as far
as National campaigns it's not at all
evident to me that this anti-woke
approach book Banning canceling all the
stuff the Wright is doing
is going to work well but we will see we
have an election coming up from YouTube
23 mistakes says perhaps telling half
the voters that they no longer make
decisions about their own bodies has
something to do with falling poll
numbers same idea you look at abortion
you look at polling on Roe v Wade and
you see that since Roe the Roe v Wade
era started started 50 years ago support
for abortion being legal in most cases
has only gone up and it reached its
highest point right around the time that
the Supreme Court did away with Roe v
Wade and it did play a role in the
November of 2022 midterms maybe not as
big a role as it would have played if it
had been closer in time to the election
it was you know some months but
you look at the polling and you look at
opinion surveys about what Americans
want and you see most Americans do
believe abortion should be legal most of
the time so then why would you have an
entire political movement social
conservatism based around ending and
banning abortion doesn't seem to make
sense
we will see if they suffer even more as
a result of that in 2024 and of course I
hope that they do consequences for
actions it's a beautiful thing lastly
Pam Hall
says very disappointed in Pacman who had
endorsed Williamson on another of his
podcasts why he is throwing her under
the bus now over a gaff is the real
question
please
criticize me for things I said
I never endorsed Marianne Williamson my
position on Marianne Williamson has not
changed since I learned about her since
I became woke to Marianne Williamson
very nice person
has great empathy and shares many of my
broader ideals and is not interesting to
me as a presidential candidate for many
reasons that I've gone over including
lack of EX of relevant experience in a
number of different areas previous
statements that I find completely
antithetical to my worldview about
everything from
depression to other things
I don't know you know the problem is
I simplify simplify simplify to try to
be to make it impossible to be
misunderstood
but then I don't provide enough contexts
so that causes a problem and then when I
go Nuance expand Nuance context people
don't listen to the whole thing and then
they go you endorsed her on another
podcast when what are you talking about
what what on Earth are you talking about
endorsed in what sense what does that
even mean so listen Marianne Williamson
should run she is running it's not up to
me anybody who wants to run should run I
would like I would prefer the DNC have
debates they're not going to it has
nothing to do with me the DNC is not
going to have debates because why would
you do something that could jeopardize
the campaign of whoever is sort of like
the de facto nominee doesn't matter who
it is they're not going to have debates
I would like to see debates and you
would just have to figure out what
polling threshold would be required to
make it into the democratic debate would
it be four percent six percent eight
percent in the polling I don't know but
you'd have to find some threshold and I
would love to see a debate with Joe
Biden Marianne Williamson you know Bobby
Kennedy Jr to the extent that he's a
Democrat and he's running and has
polling support which he does in in some
polls put him on a stage that's great I
think it's fantastic am I supporting
Marianne Williamson for president no I'm
not but that doesn't mean I don't think
she should run or that she should be
silenced or whatever the case may be
criticize me if you disagree with what I
actually believe
not random usings that are about things
I've never said info davidpackman.com
you might be featured in next week's
Friday Feed Bag feedback
Friday
Etc uh we've got a great bonus show for
you today sign up at joincochman.com we
will see you then for Monday
foreign